it's great to see you thanks for uh
thanks for coming out to do this man I'm
really excited for you this has been a
long time coming I think I said to you
like six or seven years you see like the
very beginning of the podcast I was like
well let me know when the books done and
you know come and tell me about it and I
was like I wonder if that guy's ever
gonna finish that book every time we've
seen each other you're like so how's it
how's it going Alex was I that tired no
that doesn't came off to me because
inside for me I was I was drowning you
know this has been seven years I can't
believe you've been working on this book
for seven years so just to kind of lay
the foundation for this I remember this
is how we sort of first connected and
met my editor on finding ultra at crown
is an amazing guy called Rick Oregon who
we can talk about because he deserves to
be recognizable and I was having a phone
conversation with him I can't even
remember whether finding ultra had even
come out yet like it was probably
sometime in 2012 he's like hey I'm
working on this book with this young guy
he's really cool I think he'd really
like him like I want to I want to
connect you guys like he is gonna be a
really cool book and that's when your
name first came up and we had lunch I
can't remember when that was but real
food a long time ago yeah and you told
me your story which I thought was
amazing in this book that you were
working on and then we would bump into
each other once or twice a year and I'd
be like how's the book on and you know
what's funny is that I know other people
who get stuck in this kind of situation
where they're working on a book and it
gets protracted and a lot of them don't
end up finishing yeah so I was like I
wonder if it maybe he's never gonna
finish this book like I you know it's
gonna happen here you know so here we
are it's coming out in James God I'm
proud of you I feel very emotionally
invested you can visit journey everyone
so it's really cool though and thank you
for all the encouragement along the way
yeah it's great I mean we so Rick
Corrigan was your editor on this
and just so people understand like when
I first pitched finding ultra like when
you when you write a book you write a
proposal I'm sure you did you did this
as well right and then and then my book
agent sent it out to a couple publishing
houses and she was very tempered with me
she's like listen you really got to
thread the needle here you have a good
story but like you know it's really
tough out there and like you know I'm
gonna do my best but I'm just not sure
and then we got a bite with crown she's
like we got a call with crown and it was
my very first like pitch it over the
phone I've never done anything like that
before I was like you're gonna have like
10 minutes or five minutes on the phone
with this guy like you gotta sell
yourself so we did this call and I
remember I was like at the Calabasas
Commons it's like oh yeah and the
service was not very good and I had I
like hid behind a bush like do this like
make sure there wasn't any kind of like
noise and I was like crouched down and
did this call and it went well and he
ended up like bidding on the book he
really wanted the book and we ended up
selling finding ultra to crown and I
remember saying to my book agent I'm
gonna bring this around to you don't
worry I remember saying to my book agent
yeah but this guy Rick Corrigan like
he's not actually gonna be my editor
right like they're gonna assign me some
kind of a junior person because this guy
Rick Corrigan who I later found out I
would have panicked on the phone had I
known this during the call had like
edited you know Hillary Clinton's
biography was the rise when he books you
know his book yeah I'm like this guy's
way too
senior and important to be interested in
what I'm doing you know I was like no no
he's gonna be your editor
and we had this amazing collaboration
and I learned so much about the art of
writing and storytelling and he really
pushed me and I remember at one point he
said to me he goes listen here's the
little secret dirty little secret about
New York editors and the publishing
industry editors don't really edit
because they have too many books so you
have this romantic idea that you're
going to have this amazing relationship
with this editor and you're going to be
on the phone with him at midnight having
these conversations about full
Sophie you know and it's like it doesn't
work that way and he was basically
saying like I don't have time to really
even read everything that's coming
across my desk that I'm responsible for
but I really like your story and I
really want to help you and I want to
make this book the best that it can be
and he really did roll up his sleeves
and and and he really helped the book
become the book that it became and I
couldn't have done it without him and
I'm just forever grateful to him and so
I'm interested first and I would imagine
you had a similar relationship with him
yeah you nailed it
when I first met Rick so I've been
through three different because I've
been working on this for seven years and
turnover in the publishing industry is
very high now I've gone through three
different editors right because he left
crown he left crown but he was my
original editor right and the thing Rick
did that changed my life and I really
mean that is when I had originally
started this book it was a book about in
my head you know I'm this eighteen year
old kid I'm gonna go interview all these
people who I admire figure out how they
launched their careers in each chapters
a different person you know chapter one
is Bill Gates chapter two is Warren
Buffett and that was my thinking about
so it took two years until I got the
deal with crown and then a year into the
deal Rick calls me into his office and
you're gonna appreciate this
he calls me into his office and he has
that like gruff New York voice right and
he's like Alex what's the goal of this
book the other saying this is a year
into me room working with Barry so we're
clear up it's a very strange question
again and he's like what's the what's
the goal is it to change people's lives
or to inform them and I'm like that's
clearly a leading question yeah oh I
want to try to change lives and he goes
well the book you're writing isn't gonna
do that and I'm like we've been working
together for a year how are you bringing
this up just now he's like well I have a
son your age you wouldn't have listened
and essentially what he told me is that
if you look at any magazine QA you know
there might be great information in
there but it's never changed a life
mmm-hmm but if you look at all this
and we have you talked about this in our
first lunch I don't know if you remember
but the stories that changed lives of
this same story arc you know there's
this person who everyone can relate to
and as you know she or he goes on this
journey and evolves so does the reader
mm-hmm and that's how you change
someone's life yeah I do remember having
that conversation with you and I think
that's one of the reasons why he
suggested that you read finding ultra
because one of the things that was sort
of core and key
I mean look my book is about my story
it's different than your book but but I
think what he was trying to convey to
you is you have to get people
emotionally invested in what you're
doing here and if it's to drive its just
informational you're never gonna have
that connection so people aren't gonna
be I was engaged with the materials they
could be they need to see it through
your eyes in your experience so to the
extent that you can invest yourself
right in this story and make your
journey core to that narrative the
better off you're gonna be in that quest
to transform lives and you've
accomplished math I mean that's
ultimately thank you in this book right
and took me really like at least three
months because I think when we had first
spoken I was in that three month period
of like awkwardness of not knowing if I
was gonna follow Rick's advice or not
cuz I had spent years saying I was not
gonna even use my name in the book like
this wasn't about me at all and what
Rick had to you know drill in my
textbook essentially and he helped me
realize look it's not about you
literally you're a conduit for the
reader mm-hmm and that's how the book is
now right you have to be a cipher you
have to be a stand-in for a audience
exactly yeah cool so let's uh let's talk
about how it all came together I mean
your story's so crazy like how old were
you when I first met you you know
anything like that I had just turned 20
when you then I first met you were just
you would just turn so I've been working
on the book for about two years right
all right so backing it up from there
well let's go all the way back you grew
up in Los Angeles Iranian Jews your
grandfather was living in Iran like I
love this story about your grandfather
because I think that I feel like you're
you share a lot of DNA with him and I
feel like that part of your story kind
of informs your ethos and perspective on
business and life so and it's so funny
because I didn't know this story until
much later in my life and I was a kid
who sort of kept secret from us to fully
understand who I am you actually have to
go back like you said you know 90 years
ago when my grandfather was born and he
was born in Persia and Iran he was the
youngest of six siblings so five older
siblings boy four girls and then him and
when my grandfather was three years old
his father passed away and the thing you
have to know about Iran at that time is
that woman weren't really allowed to
work shows up to the men in the family
to provide thankfully there was an older
brother and he was about 18 so he
started working and take care of the
family and then two years after that the
older brother dies so now the only male
left in the family is the five year old
mm-hmm child my grandpa but the mom
thankfully was very wise and she said
look you're going to school and I'll
find ways to make ends meet so she's
selling you know her wedding ring she's
selling the voss in the living room
she's just making things work barely you
know putting food on the table and by
the time my grandpa was about eight or
nine he realized this isn't very
sustainable so he was flipping through
the newspaper one day and in I think it
might've been the classified section he
sees a order from the Iranian government
asking for paint thinner for a
government building and he's like nine
years old and I think he was like an
apprentice at a local shop so he knew
like what a you know an assertion order
is so he he like gets out the bid and he
just but because he's not he doesn't
know how much the cost of these things
are he fills it out and sends it in and
because he gave such a low bid he he won
the contract because they don't know
that he's nine no no we're on the floor
you must have been fine so you know he
wins this bid and he's nine years old
has no idea what to do so he you know
goes to the bazaar and has this you know
family friend who has paint thinner and
he's you know gets the paint thinner
from this guy gives it to the government
makes a profit and he even remembers
like buying like pistachios on the way
home and it was like this big bag of
pistachios and he was like the happiest
day of his life a couple weeks later
he's in geometry class and he's in like
elementary school right and the police
show up and in his class and they pull
him out of class and they say the paint
thinner you gave us is expired and if
you don't get us new paint thinner
you're gonna have a serious problem
hmm and you run especially when you're a
Jew and Iran when the police are saying
you have a serious problem they're
literally gonna arrest and imprison and
it's not even Teresa and it's yeah it's
so wild cuz what he ends up doing is he
goes back to that family friend and says
hey the paint thinner you gave me is
expired and he goes that's your problem
not mine mm-hmm so now my grandpa has to
go you know this young little Jewish boy
in this you know bizarre and Tehran ends
up finding another paint thinner dealer
who uses his profits to buy that paint
thinner gives it to the government and
is home free but that sort of sets him
on this track of you know doing more
orders for the government and he starts
getting better at it and better at it in
the meantime he's getting his you know
PhD in chemistry and by age 50 he had
done really well for himself he had one
of the you know tallest buildings in the
you know nation's capital you know
working on the top floor and at age 50
he had four kids my mom included and
right around then the Iranian Revolution
happens and they did something very
ingenious very cruel Bavarian genius
which is before the Revolution literally
started
he sort of created this list of
influential Jews that they needed to
take out
to make it much easier to have the
revolution and my grandpa was on that
list unknowingly so he's in his office
one day and it's still crazy to hear him
tell this story because he doesn't do it
often but to my understanding you know
loads of men with like you know masks
over the head breaking through the
ground floor and surround the building
go up all the staircases to the point
where he knew like through a telephone
system that they were coming and he had
like 30 seconds but all the staircases
were covered and there's one part of the
story that's crazy which is he got his
passport and like threw it into an air
and air conditioning vent and told his
assistant who was Muslim look they're
not gonna get you they're only here to
get me like recover my passport in case
I find a way out and you know my grandpa
gets captured at gunpoint they put like
a bag over his head and take him to this
compound which is essentially an
execution compound and even to this day
when I asked him about the scariest time
he's been through a lot and when I asked
him about the scariest time in his life
he said it was there because every night
you would hear gunshots and a different
person who's being held doesn't come
back so you figure out very it's not
like the reading you Miranda rights
you're just no there yeah yeah so you're
just you're counting down until you're
the person who's pissed yeah and you
know my grandpa is trying to find a way
out of this thing he's trying to you
know talk his way out offer bribes like
nothing and soon enough over the speaker
they call his name and they put a bag
over his head and you know walk him down
this corridor and when the bag comes off
he's out of the compound one of the
guards had taken the bribe and my
grandpa you know escapes Iran during the
Revolution makes it to America as a
refugee and sadly actually has to go
back to where he was 50 years ago you
know with nothing having to rebuild a
life except this time he has a wife and
four kids
he's Briggs he's able to bring his
family yeah and so that's how your
parents
that to my mom my mom came here as a
teenager through the revolution so my
grandpa again just I think 12 failed
businesses in America before he started
this random spectrophotometer company
and you know has rebuilt his life but
what that story really shows me is that
it's just this incredible story of
possibility which is he started out in
this unbelievably dire situation build
himself up and was taken to the darkest
place that I can't even understand and
was able to come out the other end
mm-hmm so that's really what he lost the
perseverance but also like this guy I
mean what he was doing in elementary
school like that's just built into the
fabric of his DNA is like a little Gary
Vee hustler yeah like you know right out
of the womb and I see I see aspects of
that elements of that in in your in your
path I appreciate that thank you and I
mean like I think you're you're caring
part of your grandfather with you I mean
is he still around
yeah you know that craziest thing he's
still around he's 92 and still goes to
the office he doesn't know another way
to live yeah he's never taken a vacation
yeah it's wild well I would imagine part
of that is you know when you've suffered
to the extent that he hasn't lost it
like there's a connection with holding
on to it or continuing to grow something
yeah it's probably a little bit more
deep then we can understand yeah what
he's been through is like you said it's
very hard to understand right so your
parents really grow up in United States
all right this is so your grandfather
was on your mom's side yeah so this is
my mom's dad my dad came when he was
about 19 and my mom came when she was
about you know 10 mm-hmm and they met
here and it's you know I can't fathom
what life would have been like if I went
through what they went through as
teenagers you know leaving your entire
in they didn't come here thinking they
were refugees they came here thinking
they were coming for a two month
patient as the riots calm down back at
home then they would go back they had
all their stuff they're like oh yeah
just pack a day bag we'll be back in a
month or so and they just never been
home ever since right right right
so how does that inform like their
worldview and how does that work you
travel down expectations placed on young
Alex B'nai on well so had that affected
their worldview whether they knew it or
not was I grew up in a family where like
fear was in the walls and understandably
not to an eight-year-old Alex I'm just
like what why won't my mom let me sleep
over at a friend's house well I won't my
mom like let me go on a field trip like
without her physically driving like it
was crazy like even school trips were
giant debates in my family because there
was just this tremendous amount of
trauma that my parents had gone through
yeah and a betrayal of trust - no I save
who to trust
you know you're gonna get on a bus and
go across town right with the school the
government funded school and of course
like as a kid you I had my own
comprehension what are you talking about
I'm like we're just going to Yosemite
let us go and they're like with my
younger sister my mama said my mom
followed the bus I've never told anybody
this but you know it's a testament to my
mom's love and also to the the trauma
they went through yeah but she came over
at 10:00 does she remember what her dad
went through or is that a it's very that
she can't it's it's in your blood you
know when you're in there's a certain
amount of shame to with it because when
I was growing up I would look in family
photo albums and see my grandpa wasn't
in pictures for like a year period or
two year period and now to ask where he
was and they would say to Daanish gob
Buddha which means he was at the
University mm-hmm it wasn't till I was
18 I found out he is actually right
that's Kevin telling you what it
actually no so it was almost this like
skeleton in my family's closet that my
grandpa was held to be it's hard to
understand why
that would create shame though it
certainly wasn't you know by any fault
of his you you do have to spend more
time with purchasing create shame it's
like all the way I poured my water it's
very shameful alright so so you come out
of the womb though and they're like this
kid's gonna be a doctor
yeah because again I exact I came out of
the womb my mom cradles me in her arms
and stamps MD on my ass and sends me on
my way and that's what happens when
you're the son of you know these Persian
Jewish immigrants where and have a bunch
of friends who I grew up with who went
through the same thing because and this
is something my grandma would tell me in
a revolution they can take your money
they can take your possessions but they
can't take away what you know and if
you're a doctor and you can save people
no one can take that away from you
mmm-hmm so me being a doctor as a kid
wasn't this like amazing fun fantasy it
was like and it was a very focused
cemented life track I wore scrubs to
school for Halloween I went to pre-med
summer camp in high school
and by the time I got to college I was
like the pre-med of primettes
and it wasn't until the first month
where I was living in the dorms that I
wasn't surrounded by my parents my
grandparents and this weird phenomenon
happened all these things that in my
entire childhood were my identity
started sucking the life out of me I
remember looking at this like towering
stack of biology books feeling like they
were like Dementors totally sucking the
soul and at first they assumed maybe I'm
just being lazy and that's when I
started to wonder well what if I'm not
on my path
what if I'm on a path somebody placed me
on and I'm just rolling down and thus
ensues like this life crisis of it
wasn't about switching a major as much
as it was changing my identity right and
prior to that I would imagine you didn't
spend a lot of time really contemplating
what makes you happy or
would be fulfilling for you there's the
ocean of happiness and an immigrant
family yeah I mean my my you know my
rearing is very different than yours but
you know I can relate to that like I was
you know in a somewhat analogous
situation and it took me a lot longer to
that kind of dawning epiphany yeah much
earlier but I understand on some level
you know what that's like and and and
you know coming up in this family where
Shane was very much a part of the sort
of you know family it's not a part of is
there anything more Shane provoking than
confronting the fact that you may not
want to pursue this path that you've
been on your whole life and what would
that look like you know in terms of
communicating that your parents oh my
god it was terrifying because when I
first started even questioning what I
wanted to do with my life going through
that life crisis I couldn't tell my
parents I was even questioning it it was
almost like I was living this double
life where my mom would call me and ask
um my pre-med classes were going ah my
god it's great then I would like hang up
on her and like sneak the 4-hour
workweek under my like blanket and read
it were you still enrolled in the
pre-med classes or had you know yeah
yeah of course
but you're just you know checked out
yeah and it's so funny because a part of
me thought I was being a slacker but in
hindsight I was like I said I was like
sneaking the 4-hour workweek into class
and reading it so I was working hard
just on these other things because the
questions that evolved naturally were
okay not only do I not know what I want
to do with my life how did all these
people who I look up to how did they do
it you know how did Bill Gates when he
was a sophomore in college 19 years old
nobody knew his name so softer out of
his dorm room or had it spielberg when
he was rejected from film school become
the youngest director in Hollywood
history so I thought all right before I
figure out what I am gonna do let me
just get some base knowledge so I can
figure it out so I just went to the
library and just ripped through these
biographies and business folks and
self-help books
but eventually I was left empty-handed
and that's when this naive
eight-year-old thinking kicked in and I
thought well if no one's gonna write the
book I'm dreaming of reading why not
just write it myself right and you're a
tease here are you a freshman in college
and it doesn't really it's like the
perfect caliber of naive where I'm dumb
enough to not know anything but I also
like have resources in the sense that
like I'm in a dorm room with a computer
in a lot of free time it's like the
perfect combination
yeah naivete is underestimated like
there's nothing like the power of not
really knowing what you're getting into
like looking back now seven years later
like had you known okay this is gonna be
a seven year adventure yeah like with
all of these pitfalls and valleys you
would have never undertaken it if you
really understood what it entailed
yeah and that's I like think about this
all the time that well there's like
tremendous value in being an expert in a
field you know you have connections you
have all this knowledge and expertise
one of the biggest you know advantages
of being naive and being an amateur is
you're not limited in the way an expert
is because an expert sees the world
through a lens of limitation because
they know how things work but at you
know someone who's naive sees into a
world of possibility and that is
incredibly powerful and I can understand
how at that time you would think well
how hard can it be like I'm just gonna
go find all these people that are super
awesome and I'm gonna you know interview
them and they're gonna be happy to sit
down with the elites helps kids all the
time you know I won't leave right that
was my thinking but the idea was from
the very beginning like this is gonna be
a book I'm gonna write a book my
thinking was you know I was smart enough
to know Bill Gates who won't do an
interview for a blog right because if
you're writing a book you're legit and
this is the book like this is a book you
wish had been available in the library
that would that would convey all the
secrets and the wisdom to a young person
about how to answer that question what
should I do with my life
yeah pours out correct at its core at
that time especially it was less about
an age and more about us
when someone's starting out it doesn't
matter if it's you know they're starting
out from college or they're an executive
switching industries when you're just
starting out and no one wants to take
your calls no one wants to take your
meetings how do you find a way to break
through because that was my problem and
I didn't want to book just focused on
business or just focus on entertainment
I wanted a book that covered every
industry so what ended up happening is
me and my best friends one night and you
actually know one of them Kevin heck
yeah so you know we're all 18 I call
them up in like guys you know I need
your help because I didn't know what
really the definition of success was so
I didn't know who to interview and I
don't really believe in these like
Forbes 100 lists so I was like guys if
we can create our dream University who
would be our professors and then that
made it really easy you know Bill Gates
would teach business Lady Gaga music
Steve Wozniak computer science jane
goodall science Maya Angelou poetry you
know pitbull can teach Latin American
Studies you know we're just dumb
eighteen-year-old kid right okay and we
created this dream list and I wrote it
on a note card and I put in my wallet I
was like you know how hard could it be
that I assumed would be the easy part
the hard part I figured was getting
money to fund the journey right how are
you gonna do this I mean it was the idea
that you would stop out of college or
you were gonna try it all right well
college I mean there's still a looming
conversation with the parents that's out
there that's got to be causing you some
strain all of this was like my secret
double life at this point my parents
didn't know any of this was happening
that's why even with the money thing I
couldn't like talk to them and
brainstorm how to make it happen I had
to figure it out for myself because I
was you know buried in student loan debt
I was all out of our Mitzvah cash so
there had to be a way to make some quick
money so two nights before final exams
I'm in the library and I'm doing what
everyone's doing in the library I'm on
Facebook and
as I'm there and I'm on Facebook and I
see someone's posting tickets to the
prices right
and it's filming the next day and the
first I I know this sounds like
preposterous but the first thought was
what if I go on the show and win some
money to fund this dream you know not my
brightest moment but I had a bigger
problem you know I'd never seen a full
episode of the show before
I'd seen bits and pieces growing I'd
never seen a full episode Plus that
Finals in two days and I told myself was
a horrible idea and not to do it I don't
have you've ever had one of those times
where like this horrible idea keeps you
have a stupid idea of it you can't shake
it exactly so I had the stupid idea I
can shake it and I remember because they
needed to focus on studying I didn't
have much time
cuz finals were in two days I opened my
spiral notebook to make a best in worst
case scenario list to prove to myself as
a bad idea so I remember like so vividly
I'm sitting in the core this corner
table in the library and I'm like best
and worst case scenarios
you know worst case scenarios they all
finals mm-hmm get kicked out of pre-med
lose financial aid mom hates me
no mom stops talking to me you know look
fat on TV there are like 20 cons and the
only pro was maybe maybe went enough
money to fund this dream and it felt
almost as if someone had tied a rope
around my gut and was pulling in a
direction so you know that night I
decided to do the logical thing and pull
an all-nighter to study but I didn't
study for finals a study had a hack The
Price is Right
all right well first of all why not just
no other price is right after final okay
I don't know how to get tickets they
just write big like fell into my lap I
see and how do you have that's your
inner parent right now looking at me
like you idiot
I mean you know the price is right isn't
going anywhere it's been around for a
while
oh my god so alright so how do you hack
the prices right like what
secret so they make it look completely
random you know Alex come on down as if
the I pulled your name out of a hat
during my all-nighter of research I
learned there's actually a system to it
it wasn't just luck there's like blog
posts out there are people who are like
it wasn't a blog post it was like 1992
message boards with like the 50th
comment like I was your deep I was like
on the 23rd oh of Google right I'm like
super deep in this and it's around 3
a.m. where I find out there's a producer
who interviews every single person in
the audience and I then I served you
know researching everything about the
producer and I learned you know what his
name was where he was born where he went
to college I essentially knew what he
ate for breakfast that morning and then
I found out something even crazier
because you know I would assume a lot of
people know about the producer I then
found out there's also an undercover
producer who's planted in the audience
who confirm or denies the main producers
selection hmm so while some people might
know that you know you have a one-minute
interview with a producer no one knows
that you're four hours waiting in line
is an interview in and of itself right
so this person's sizing everybody up
trying to figure out who's gonna be the
best guest to get picked right so I the
second I get to the CBS studio a lot the
morning of the prices right I just you
know I don't know who the undercover
producer is I just assumed everyone was
undercover producer you know something
like dancing with the security guards
I'm flirting with old ladies I'm break
dancing and I don't know how to break
dance and I'm waiting in line and
eventually it's my turn to meet the
producer and you know I knew all about
him I knew you know that he had a
clipboard but it was never in his hands
the assistants sitting behind him you
know maybe 20 feet away has the
clipboard and if he really likes you
he'll he'll he'll keep talking and if he
wants you on the show
he'll turn around wink mm-hmm and she'll
put like put your name you knew that I
knew that going so I knew like what I
had to
accomplished I knew it wasn't just him
like shaking my hand and saying good
luck I knew I had to see the physical
check right so I get there and I'm
standing right in front of him and he's
like you know he has a rhythm he's like
what's your name where you're from what
do you do and I go hey I'm Alex um I'm
18 I'm a freshman in college I'm a
pre-med and it goes whoa whoa whoa
you're pre-med you probably spend a lot
of time studying how do you have time to
watch The Price is Right and I go oh is
that where I am like I don't even get a
pity laugh like you're giving me more so
I don't even get a pity laugh and I can
see his eyes wandering and my quickly
and you know I had to do something and
in one of those business books I had
read and might I think it was like a
Tony Robbins book it said human contact
speeds up a relationship so I had an
idea I needed to touch Stan so I I go to
the producer stand I'm like Stan like
come over here I want to make a
handshake with you and he you know is
very hesitated I'm like come on come on
and he he comes over I teach him how to
pound it and blow it up mm-hm and you
know he laughs and he's like oh you're
gonna do great good luck and starts
walking away you know it doesn't turn
around and strike two
that doesn't the assistant is writing on
a clipboard and this was like one of
those moments where you can see your
entire dream like right in front of you
and see it walking away almost like
slipping through your hands like sand
and the worst part was that you know you
didn't even have a chance to fully prove
yourself so I don't know what got into
me but I started yelling at the top of
my lungs the whole shoots their head
around like are you what's going on and
Stan runs over like they think I'm
having a seizure he's like are you okay
what's happening and now I have no idea
what I'm gonna say so I'm just looking
at him he's either gonna get tossed out
for being a lunatic but my thinking was
you know what are already gone yeah
what's the point of staying
all right I'm not on the show at this
point so I might as well go all the way
in so I'm looking at him he's looking at
me in this guy's like you know typical
Hollywood like turtleneck turtleneck you
know red scarf even though it's 70
degrees he's like and I I just look at
him and I'm like your scarf and now I
really don't know what I'm gonna say
next
and you know there it's dead silent like
ever there's so much tension right now
like let's watch this grave right now so
I end up just looking at Stan with like
all the confidence I can and I just say
the only thing I can think I'm like I'm
an avid scarf collector I have three
hundred sixty two pairs my dorm room and
I'm missing that one and I'm like
freaking out and he starts cracking up
because I think he realized what I was
actually trying to do and he like gives
me his scarf he's cracking he's like
look you need this more than I do he
turns around winks and his assistant
makes a mark on the check board and you
know you're in I know man that's so
bananas like like it's not like you gave
him the secret to the universe or like
it's a wisdom that was undeniable that
made him you just you just kind of like
threw an innie I mean I was like a Hail
Mary I don't know what that was the book
journey is pretty much me desperately
throwing Hail Marys and missing nine out
of ten but the one that makes it is like
the craziest [ __ ] ever but I think you
know behind that is your willingness to
throw Hail Marys like you're you have
like look you have gumption you app
hustle you got you have charisma you
have personality I would imagine your
grandfather must have seen this in you
what did he identify you as some kind of
kindred spirit even though you were on
this and wish back you know funny enough
that's actually why he doubled down so
much on me becoming a doctor because he
didn't want me to live and suffer the
way he had to as an entrepreneur I was
almost like he saw too much of himself
and you and wanted something different
for you that's crazy I never thought of
that yeah so alright so you can you get
on the show and like you win big right
like what you win like a sailboat or
something I end up yeah
way the hacking of the show work it was
less Einstein and more Forrest Gump and
I end up winning the whole showcase
showdown winning a sailboat selling the
sailboat and that's how I funded the
book and the sailboat I sold for like
twenty thousand dollars which for a
broke college student is like a million
bucks you know my most expensive
expenses like Chipotle with guacamole so
you know I'm feeling like a billionaire
and I used that money to fund the
journey and you know it took two years
but I eventually got two gates it took
three years to get to Lady gaga and you
know it's like you said seven years
later on the book is just finally thin
right and and you so you take this money
do you end up stopping out of school are
you still a student while you're doing
this so I'm still a student cuz you know
I love college and my I had some
awareness of just how much my parents
had sacrificed for me to be in school I
remember so when I got into college my
mom said I couldn't go because we can
afford it and she really really insisted
on me going to a community college that
was less expensive but I remember my dad
you know the night before the deadline
enrollment date the day you have to
either confirm or deny and my mom was
like a hundred percent against me going
and I remembered through the walls
hearing my dad like cry my dad never
cried know like I'd funeral and just
never would cry the first time I had
ever heard him cry in the house and my
life was that night pretty much telling
my mom he'd do whatever it takes and I
had to go and my mom said yes so I
understood that how how much my parents
had given to help make this impossible
so dropping out wasn't even on the radar
but what ended up happening is now that
I had won The Price is Right I was like
gung-ho on making this this mission come
come together and to me the holy grail
of energy
is was Bill Gates because when I was 18
I thought you know if anyone had the
answers to the universe and had to be
Bill Gates so I spent a whole year
trying to get in contact with gates his
office and part of that is to legitimize
this project not only to yourself but to
your parents and to kind of solidify
that this is a real thing maybe
subconsciously like I wouldn't be
surprised if that was going on in my
subconscious what I was thinking at the
time was and you know this might sound
like a naive idea to some people but to
me I really believe it which is I just
really believe that if all these people
come together you know not for press not
to promote anything but really just to
share their best wisdom with the next
generation young people can do so much
more
yeah it's and that's an altruistic pitch
that's a pitch that's hard to turn down
if you're somebody like Bill Gates all
right that was that was my home that was
my huh to my surprise Bill Gates doesn't
do interviews with 18 year old Collins
so you know I spend a year getting in
contact with Gates's office and finally
at you know a year into it I'm 19 I get
it on the phone with gates his chief of
staff and we're on the phone and you
know you talked about that was that the
Calabasas smart where you're on the
phone of crown yeah so I have a similar
story where I'm in a CVS parking lot
holding an ice cream cone when my phone
rings and I see like the Seattle area
code and I knew who was I pick up the
phone and on the line is Bill Gates his
chief of staff who like it's a Melinda
bill in this guy right like they run it
it's crazy and he's like so you wanna
interview bill huh it's very good
I'm like yeah it's my biggest year I'm
the 19 I'm like it's my biggest dream
and he's like look I I love what you're
doing yeah I love that you're doing this
to help others and I'm like thinking I'm
you know 95 percent there and he's like
what thing is we don't really do
interviews like this
he's like especially you know with some
with a book that doesn't have a
publisher and he's like look if you can
go get a publishing deal from you know
either penguin or Random House and go
build more momentum call me back
click so that then you know was now you
have a mission so now well I was torn a
part of me was like my head in my hands
but a few days later I was like okay
fine he told me what I needed I what's
the what the [ __ ] is Random House like I
had no idea like how hard could that be
so I then go on this eight-month journey
of you know getting rejected every
single day trying to get this publishing
deal because I was a 19 year old kid
trying to write a business book and
write you like just it's let's just take
a step back and like analyze the
preposterous nature of that and I'm
going to I'm like God hear your biggest
business achievement is like hacking
prices right and the funny thing is to
you know maybe if I had interviews lined
up it would be a better thing but I
remember my book pros oh it was like
interviews that I'm very likely to get
honest so so I would imagine you put a
proposal to go how did you get it in
front I read Corgan and sell him on the
idea of doing this book with you so what
I had learned over so at this point I'm
about a year into my journey and you
know I'm reading every business
biography I'm and I'm getting like some
good interviews I'm interviewing Tim
there is some you know there's some
there's some early traction and one
thing I had learned is that and Tim
Ferriss actually gave me this in my
interview with him he gave me this cold
email template where he launched his
career by emailing VIPs and CEOs and he
gave me this cold email template that
gave me sort of this like amazing - I
don't know if you want me to go into it
but he given me this tool that I then
used to email about 30 different New
York Times best-selling authors asking
for their advice on how to get a book
deal mm-hmm
and the overwhelming advice I got from
all of them they gave me a lot of you
know tactics but the biggest thing was
the number one thing to getting you know
if you're unknown the number one thing
to getting a big publisher is a big
agent you know no big agent no big
publisher so my thinking was no big
agent no bit no bill gates
so that eight months journey was really
about getting the agent and once I got
the agent and you know I was rejected by
dozens and dozens of it's just crazy
yeah but when I finally got the
publishing deal well this is a month
before I got the publishing deal I got
the agent and she had told me look Alex
you know we're not gonna go to the
publishers during Christmastime that's
you know crazy we can either go next
month or we can wait for the spring it's
up to you and I knew it's already been a
like almost a year since I spoke to Bill
Gates chief of staff and I was like look
I can't wait anymore like he's probably
already forgotten about me I need to
make this happen the only problem was my
junior of college was starting the next
week and I knew you know trying to
finish my proposal in a month was hard
enough to begin with doing it while
balancing school was impossible and
that's when I had to make at the time
the hardest decision of my life between
moving forward on my dream but turning
back on my parents sacrifice in their
dreams so how'd that conversation go a
conversation is a very generous so
what's crazy is when I started on my
book even before I even talked about
leaving college you know my grandparents
and my parents sort of sniffed this was
coming so my grandma who you know I love
dearly I was just on the phone with her
30 minutes ago an hour ago she was like
fine you want to you want to write this
book you know in your part-time fine
you're not gonna become one of those you
know crazy American kids who drops out
of college and travels the world to find
himself you know she had seen the movies
she's like begu junuh men swear on my
life that you'll graduate undergrad and
get your masters and only then will I
support what you're doing
I like how she threw math master's
degrees oh my slid that in there too oh
my god and it was non-negotiable too
cuz she understood that you know in
America these days an undergrad doesn't
have the guarantees I used to and I was
like fine fine I promise and she goes no
big ooh Juna man which literally means I
swear on your life it's the strongest
promise in the world so fast forward a
year later when I'm talking about
leaving school this June and man
promises looming overhead so I had a
problem because I don't want to I don't
want to break my grandma's promise I
didn't want to ruin you know my mom's
dreams so I call my mentor who I know
you know Elliott this know and I tell
him Elliott this is I don't know what to
do how can I choose between my family
because you know family is the most
important but at what point do I stop
living for them and start living for
myself and he's like I don't understand
the problem
and I'm like well dude I the only way I
can get this publishing deal and get to
Bill Gates is if I drop out of school
and he goes whoa whoa whoa you are not
dropping out of school and I was like
what and he's like look no one smart
actually drops out of school go you know
do your research and you'll see what I'm
saying
and he hangs up I don't like what is he
talking about and he ends up sending me
on this you know mini like 24 hour quest
where I started ripping through
Zuckerberg and Bill Gates his
biographies and I finally found out what
Ellie was talking about when Zuckerberg
had started you know the Facebook that
summer he was working on a full
time he went to go meet with Peter Thiel
to get a half million dollar investment
in teal goes to Zuckerberg you're gonna
drop out of school right suck works like
not a chance
teal is like okay let's see what happens
and even when school was starting
Zuckerberg still didn't want to drop out
it was only his friend Dustin Moskovitz
who was like look man will barely
survive you know if we did this
full-time let's take one semester off
and see what happens then I looked at
Bill Gates historian and I realized he
did the same thing he took one semester
off to work on Microsoft and when it
wasn't working out he actually went back
to Harvard which no one talks about yeah
I didn't know that yet no one no one
talks about this that bill ever calls
the Bill Gates dropped out of college
and you know through his middle finger
in the sky no he actually went back to
school and things weren't working out as
well as he wanted so I called Elliot
back up and he's like bingo yeah don't
drop out
take one semester off and it doesn't
work you didn't break your grandma's
promise so I feel like I just discovered
the secret to life so I like drive to my
college campus I ask for like this leave
of absence form which says I have a
seven year window I Drive home to tell
my parents the good news this is not
good news literally I remember my mom
yelling my son not in college just you
know she's gone hysterical and four
weeks I'm just going back and forth of
them and at the end I had to come to
terms with although my mom might be
right although this might be the biggest
mistake of my life I'd rather be 80
years old and know that I tried than 80
years old and know I had failed yeah I
think the the bigger issue here is that
dividing line between living your life
or somebody else and living living it
for yourself with the understanding that
you know that this is your TrueNorth you
know it's after a year or so into this
project I think even paid your dues
enough to know like okay this is the
path for me and that's tough as a young
person it's tough for anybody in any
situation to have to wrestle with that
yeah you know the craziest thing that
happened on that day so it's the day to
turn in the leave of absence form and I
finally wait until the final day to you
know sign the form there's like two
hours left until the deadline I'm gonna
go drive to campus I'm on my parents
house I have the green form I folded up
in my pocket and I hear the doorbell
ring so you know I grab my car keys and
I walk towards the door and they turned
the knob and I opened it up and standing
on the front step is my grandma you know
just tears streaming down her face and
still to this day I'll never forget what
that felt like
and how is it now oh I love her she's
mean I feel like yeah half the time I
run into you at this event or that event
you're with like a family member so I
figured I feel like it all worked out
you have a picture with you know even
you cow and my parents at one of the in
queue shows always callow not picture
too I don't I don't think you guys knew
each other yet no you know what's funny
and I want to talk about Carroll in a
minute but I just ran into cow like a
week ago where was it
I was down at Dodger Stadium to do the
Spartan thing this part yeah so Joe to
Senna who you know is the Spartan dude
there was a Spartan event at Dodger
Stadium and up in one of the sky boxes
he was doing podcast interviews and like
video interviews and so he's like come
down like I'd never met Joe in person
he's like come down like let's you know
come on my show which was great you know
we had a great time totally cool and
then he's like hey I'm also like I'm
doing this documentary thing I'm trying
to he's like I'm taking this god I'm
putting this guy through cases you know
I'm trying to get him fit I'm trying to
sort out his diet and like he just
the guy's not listening I'm having such
a hard time because will you talk to him
find out him before you know well first
of all I must say who it was
he's like will you talk to him like
we're doing this it maybe will film you
a little bit like we'll have a little
interaction I was like yeah whatever you
want so we go to the parking lot and
with a film camera Jo and like you know
there's a cinematographer there and like
and we walk up and Joe introduced it was
like hey this is this is cows like hi
I'm Callan I'm like like Oh Cal fuss man
like I Cal doesn't know who I am but I
was like yeah I know I know you are like
cool nice to meet you and he's wearing
the fedora hat with the Spartan
like the Spartan bandana on his Dora oh
my god and and I'm like you know I hear
from jail like you're you're you're
resisting you know so we get into this
weird conversation and the bizarre thing
is that I feel like we are we were like
ships in the night like whatever cow was
saying whatever I we were just missing
each other and I look at Joe and I go
you got your hands full with this guy
god I don't know if I can help you
I love Cal at the same time everything
you just said makes I can see that
happening yeah and I hope it's okay I
told that story no that's like very
secret you know he would probably say
the same story too because it's so next
time you you see Cal I'm gonna call as
soon as we're done I'm gonna call the
tribe home and tell him that but what's
cool wit and to bring it back around to
your story like Cal becomes we should
probably explain who Cal is and how he
kind of came into your equation so this
is probably the most miraculous
coincidence that happened on the whole
journey and there were a lot of
miraculous coincidences this was a few
years into the journey and I had just
spent eight months trying to you know
track down warren buffett writing him
letters and I was just getting rejected
at every turn to the point where at the
end of eight months I was completely
depleted you know just all the life has
beat out of me
one of my best
friends Corwin was you know trying to
get my spirits up and he like come on
let's go let's grab a bite to eat so we
go to this grocery store we grab
sandwiches and we're you know sitting on
the on the sidewalk and you know I'm
just venting to my friend you know and
I'm telling him man I don't know what
the point of this I don't know how I'm
gonna do this and he's like come on you
got a you got a interview you know you
gotta have some interviews lined up and
I'm like I got nothing and he's like
come on you got it
you gotta figure something out like dude
do you know what even if I had
interviews like I would probably [ __ ]
him up you know look what happened in
the last one and his eyes were
complaining about how hard interviewing
is this car pulls up right in front of
me the door opens an out walks Larry
King and I don't know if you want me to
go into the whole story not a story I
know the story but like it's a great
story so I think it really it it it
creates the foundation for everything
that follows like I think it's I think
it's you know an integral part of of the
whole book because I think and we can
get into this later but just to kind of
like define it now I think the value of
the book is much more the journey that
you go on to create the book than it is
the wisdom imparted by these people that
you ultimately end up talking to and yes
they're providing these insights and
that has you know tremendous value but
you're learning experientially through
this and you're answering your own
questions you know book is called the
third door and you can explain why that
is but ultimately you know you're
finding the third door all the way
through in every opportunity to try to
make this happen so it's almost like
you're you know the solutions that
you're looking for you're practicing
along the way it's a process of just
coming into an understanding of that as
you go thank you man that's feels really
good to hear so back to the story okay
so back to back to me just harassing
Larry King
so you know his car pulls up he walks
out but and it's weird because I know I
sound like this extrovert a person who's
like down too many Red Bulls but I'm
really a very shy and introverted and I
I grew up with a tremendous fear of
rejection and failure so late as Larry
King opens that car door I'm like
paralyzed and I I can almost call I call
the feeling the flinch and he's
literally walking right in front of me
right past me and goes through the store
sliding windows and I can't say a thing
and my best friend Corwin like nudge
music dude what the [ __ ] like why don't
you say something and this is where the
flinch gets very good I start explaining
all the good reasons why I shouldn't
have said anything I don't want to
bother him he's like dude come on and
you know I I'm like look he's already in
the grocery story I can't find him he's
like dude he's 80 years old how far
could he have gone right and and you're
I'm planing about how this isn't working
out and then God just delivers like this
dream you know interviewee right in
front of you exactly so just to not be
embarrassed in front of my friend I very
reluctantly get up I walk I walk through
the stores in a sliding glass windows
and I look around the bakery section no
Larry no sorry I jog over to the produce
section you know fruits vegetables no
Larry and that's when I remember I had
spent or no Larry had parked in the
loading zone which meant he was leaving
any minute now so that like bolt of
adrenaline and the fear of you know
failing again you know overtakes me I
start sprinting through this grocery
store going down every aisle no Larry no
Larry no Larry no Larry no area you know
I cut down the frozen food section
you know I'm dodging old ladies like I'm
you know swerving around cans of tuna
fish no Larry so he has to be at the
checkout counter
so no Larry no Larry no Larry no Larry
and at this point I want to you know
kick myself because it was like you said
was right in front of me and I blew it
so I'm walking out of the parking lot
and I'm looking down at my feet and I
lift my gaze and right there 20 feet in
front of me is Larry King and similar to
that stand story I told you about on The
Price is Right this feeling like
overtakes me I just I'm trying to
project but I think all of this you know
pent-up anger and energy inside me
combusted and I accidentally shout mr.
gay in the neck it was an indoor parking
lot so echoed and literally I'll never
forget the look on Larry King's the poor
guy he's had like quadruple bypass
surgery he like jumps up like this his
shoulders are chopped and he turned his
head around slowly like like every
wrinkle in his face you know sprung back
his eyebrows to his hairline you know as
if he's seeing the Grim Reaper so he you
know starts you know heading towards a
car and I'm thinking like [ __ ] I'm too
deep in this to to stop now so I like
run after like mr. King mr. king my name
is Alex I'm you know I'm 20 years old
I've always wanted to say hi and he's
like okay hi you know goes off faster
and we're finally now in front of his
car he's like putting his groceries in
the trunk he opens the driver door and I
just go wait mr. King can I can I go
breakfast with you in his look of
confusion my god and you know he's about
to say no but he looks around at the
sidewalk and sees there's about like ten
people watching this go down right so he
better behave so he literally just like
shrugs in his life okay okay oh my God
my God thank you thank you so much um
yeah great I'll see you tomorrow and he
like gets in the car and closes the door
and I go
wait mr. king what time and he looks at
me and like starts the engine of this
car definitely hear me I'm like mr. king
what time he like puts the car to drive
I'm now standing like in front of the
car waving my arms in front of the
windshield mr. king one time and he just
looks at minis like 9 o clock and just
speeds off and the next morning you're
like a celebrity's worst nightmare like
having a little more death approached I
mean Isis a seer desperation look that's
what happens and he drop out of school
and lie to your grandma and put it all
on the line you do some crazy stuff to
try to make it work and so I go to Larry
King's restaurant and I show up there 9
o'clock there he is sitting in the
corner booth with his his friends and
you know I had a little bit of self
awareness at this point where I knew
right we're talking about Natan Al's
right she's in there is he still go
there every morning he he goes if he
goes to he has like a schedule where
every week there's a there's a every day
of the week if you name of the day of
the week I can say where he's at right
right so right that makes me sound
normal ok so I get there and I wasn't
been embarrassed by her how I had acted
the day prior so I was trying to be a
lot calmer so although there was an open
seat I didn't sit down I'm just like hey
mr. king good morning and he goes you
know sort of waves me away so I'm like
he wants some time alone with his
friends so I sit at the table next to
him waiting to be called over and ten
minutes passes thirty minutes pass an
hour passes and finally he stands up and
he's walking towards me I can like feel
my cheeks lift
and then he walks right past me and
heads for the exit
uh-huh and I I just like wave wave my
hand my Canton mr. king and he goes what
is it kid what do you want and at this
point I'm just like I have no energy and
I'm just like honestly I just wanted
some advice on how to interview people
in this smile like spreads across his
face almost as if to say why didn't you
say so
what do you think he thought you were
trying to do in hi he deals with a lot
of crazy people anyone of his caliber
especially someone as approachable as
Larry you have to understand he when he
was at CNN he was if not be one of the
most recognizable faces on earth he also
doesn't hide from the public likely you
said he's out you know right like if you
want it if you want to find him you can
find him like he doesn't ensconced
himself in his house like he's out in
the public side he's probably getting
rolled up on quite a bit right
especially by crazy kids I was like
urinal next to him anyway I have a funny
movie story with him later
so he's like you know he smiles and he
ends up you know putting a hand on my
shoulder and giving me you know this one
minute monologue of the best interview
advice I'd ever heard and at the end of
this monologue he goes he like looks up
almost as if he's like debating
something in his mind and he looks at me
in the eyes and I puts a finger on my
face goes all right kid tomorrow 8:45
see ya yeah and I show up the next
morning at 8:45 he calls me over to his
table I sit down he asked me like what
are you what are you even trying to
interview for and I tell him out the
book and he's like alright I'm in and
over the course of the past few years
I've been a breakfast with him about 50
times Wow
and this all comes full circle because
the
next thing that happens at the table is
we start talking about the book on that
first morning of breakfast and all right
now this is the second morning this is
my first morning at the table and I'm
telling him about my dream and he goes I
got someone you want I want you to me
hey God and this younger guy who's you
know in his late 50s because everyone
else at the tables in their 80s it's
younger guy in a fedora turns around and
there he goes you have a minute and you
know sort of sends me off with Cal and
Cal I learned
Larry tells me that his name is Cal fuss
Minh and he is you know the writer of
Esquire magazine's what I've learned
Colin and he's interviewed Muhammad Ali
Mikhail Gorbachev George Clooney you
know every person who's defined culture
the past 50 years and Cal's a New York
Times bestselling author and Cal and I
end up for what's supposed to be a
minute conversation we talk for three
hours and that conversation turns into
another conversation the next day and
Cal and I you know create this
relationship where he realizes how much
help I need because I have this big
lofty dream of writing a book that
changes people's lives yet I have zero
writing experience and Cal was working
in the magazine industry when I was
shrinking at a very scary rate and he
didn't know he didn't even know how to
create a Twitter account forget about
how to tweet he even know where the long
full analog so we sort of Creed this
relationship where I start helping him
with his you know his you know create a
Twitter account I make a website for him
and he starts teaching me how to like
write a sentence and like again like a
miracle while the Larry a situation
feels like a miracle what Cal did for me
was a miracle and he sat down with me
over the past almost four years every
you know every week at least three times
a week for about three hours at a time
over my chapters and teaching me how to
write that's amazing and that's a why do
you think he was willing to invest so
much of his energy in you the obvious
number one is he's so kind and you know
you can't you can't fake it
you're either you have that harder you
don't um I got that I actually asked
this guy who I met he's really smart guy
he was the used to be a VP at Goldman
Sachs and I asked him cuz he was giving
me a lot of advice - I asked him like
how do you choose like which people to
mentor you have such little time and he
has this theory which i think is really
brilliant about why someone chooses to
mentor someone subconsciously because
it's never really a conscious decision
when you give of yourself in that way
and he said it's someone mentors you for
three reasons one and they're all
subconscious reasons one they see some
of them self in you - they want to help
you be more like them whether it's
because they have a special expertise
they want to help you with but they want
to help you and they feel they can't
help you be more like them the third one
is the most interesting they want to be
more like you mm-hmm and that's sort of
confusing but what he explained to me is
like you know if someone's a you know 70
year old CEO sometimes the thing they
need most in their life is 19 year old
enthusiasm about their company because
they're so you know lackluster at that
point right right no I totally get that
I totally get that and just not really
knowing that much about your
relationship with Cal and the dynamic
you know it's clear to see how you were
able to bring that to him because I've
watched his career change in a very
dramatic way just in the last couple
years from you know Meg James Beard
award-winner magazine writer I to a guy
who's now like
very well known in the digital universe
you know he's gone crazy in Faris's
podcast like twice I think and three
times I saw him speak at the shine and I
know our mutual friend Kevin is now his
manager and I believe you're the one who
introduced him to Elliott and then he
became a speaker at Summit and so now
he's like this guy who has you know like
this whole life and career that he could
not have conceptualized prior to meeting
you Cal I always mess with him because I
like to remind him by the way Cal's
Twitter is fantastic he puts out all
these great quotes and it gets tons of
retweets but I always joke with him
because in our first conversation I
asked him if he has a Twitter account
and he laughed in my face and said
Twitter is my kryptonite he like
literally laughed in my face and he's
just done so well and you know all
credit goes to him but like you said he
you know his podcast is incredible his
his speeches bring people to tears he he
has a newsletter now it's just night and
day and I'm just so proud of him and
he's like family to me his goddaughter
his daughter is not my goddaughter you
know I had her bum it's fine like when
I've been lit a candle and it's been one
of the biggest honors of my life super
cool and and what was it that he liked
what's the main thing that you learned
from him about writing oh wow I can you
know I have this fantasy of one day you
know after the book launch teaching like
a you know a ten-hour course of what Cal
taught me over 40 years and because I
can give you like I'll give you some
three things just off the top of my head
that are the biggest things though but I
could give a whole it's like my dream to
pay it forward because what he gave me
was life-changing
number one is man it's crazy because
when I first sat down with Cal I don't
think I've ever told this publicly in
our first conversation he said Twitter's
my kryptonite and Isis something even
more preposterous he asked me when my
plans were out of how to write the book
and I said
I'm admitting this I said cow I've heard
a lot of statistics and blog posts and I
know that with a business book and I'm
writing a business book 90% of people
don't reap ass the first chapter so I'm
not too worried and he looked at me like
[Laughter]
real writer write it is his profession
he's an artist
so Cal taught me how to do the opposite
which is how to write a book where 90
percent read the final sentence and
there's three ways to do it well there's
a lot of ways but the three main things
he taught me number one is every single
chapter there you cannot have an
exception needs to have tension every
single one I thought I could get away
with like you know the first chapter
having some tension in the middle
chapter in the fun every it doesn't
matter and that is really hard my issue
was if I was writing a fiction book
Cal's advice would have been very much
easier to implement because it was a
nonfiction book and I had to write about
some of the looks some of the chapters
were my stories and I could tell them
but some of the chapters were me and
Bill Gates sitting in an office for an
hour with an audio recorder and Bill
also recorded his team of smart enough
to also record it so I can't even change
a word of what was said in there yeah
but what you can do is describe what was
happening with you emotionally because I
feel tension just hearing that like okay
you're a kid you walk into this office
there's a whole team of people there
recording it on there and what are they
gonna do what's their agenda like how am
I going to navigate that like you know
my palms can get sweaty just hearing
about that there's a lot to work with
there
yeah well I'm so happy that you're a
brilliant writer but that's Cal had a
big job teach me that of you know every
chapter needs tension so that's number
one and actually there's this great
thing from I don't know if you've ever
seen master class yes online
incredible and there are like super high
oh it's like HBO for an online course
man Claude are you glad I won't but the
one that I recommend to any creative
writer filmmaker anyone is the Aaron
Sorkin one mmm and he in a perfect
sentence says what the key is to tension
and Cal Tommy this - he says you need a
very strong intention and very very very
crazy obstacles because you can have all
these crazy obstacles but if there's not
an intention like if I don't do X Y will
happen right like you can do a movie
magic or a consequence stakes and that's
what Cal taught me you need to have
stakes right so then you're like just to
extend the analogy of the Bill Gates
interview what are the stakes like okay
so he doesn't want to talk to me or the
interview doesn't go well like what's
the worst thing that could happen like
it's hard to come up with like stakes
that are super high well what Cal is so
good at is because he's one of the best
interviewers on earth he would help me
he wouldn't ask me questions almost like
a therapist that would pull the answers
out of me that I didn't even know like
he would like I would write the first
draft of the bill so the the Bill Gates
chapter for example that was the hardest
chapter right by far that took 134 edits
and that's before I said round meeting
drafts dress that's like insane and
that's before I sent it to crown and
then once I got to crown I went through
probably another like 32 the final one
so it's probably about 160 at this point
I've been proofreading proud it's
probably well meanwhile I'm like on my
phone looking at your Instagram and
you're like sitting down to rewrite this
chapter again I go this guy's just
afraid I'm like this guy is paralyzed
because he's so afraid of sharing what
he's written that he thinks the solution
is to rewrite it again mine's like is
this guy ever gonna like it's this thing
so cow not knowing that so cows really
so that that was going on behind the
scenes and Cal and I made a promise he
was too he's like look this is your book
I'm not gonna write a word of it so you
can't have that expectation but the one
thing I'll promise you is that if you
send me something I'll read it and I'll
let you know when it's good enough to
move on to the next chapter I was like
great now to my surprise like with Bill
Gates it took a hundred and thirty four
you know drafts for me to Cal go alright
fine move on so some of the thing okay
so we have tension that's what Cal
taught the second thing is there needs
needs needs to be a grip and that was
the hardest thing for me to understand
and what he means by that is every
chapter on every story you can't just
you know throw it out so there's a
chapter where I go to meet Mark
Zuckerberg and it ends up being a
disaster because security comes and they
think I'm an impostor and they
threatened to call the police and it's
this whole crazy story but I'll tell you
for example the opening of that chapter
is the founder of Ted once told me I
live my life by two mantras one if you
don't ask you don't get in to most
things don't work out and that created
this grip that or some people might call
it a frame to almost and there's a sense
of confidence that you know someone like
Al has over writing that you really have
to grab it like a you know slab a clean
hole grip it in your hand and throw it
down on the table as opposed to just
sort of being like it was a bright
summer day when I got the email from
Mark Zuckerberg that year the story owns
you you need to own the story so that's
number two is grip it and number three
which is a very practical one and again
why the book took so long to write this
is the attention of detail Cal forced me
thankfully to have with the writing of
this book every sentence he said you
need to treat like a restaurant and
every sentence by the way this isn't
this book is about 80,000 words
so we're looking at about 8,000
sentences right maybe more maybe less
and he goes think of it like a
restaurant the first word is the maitre
d it invites you in and then the pacing
of that sentence needs to depend on what
the mood is of the customer is it a
straight through a course is it
fast-food then you can't have commas in
that sentence is it an a course meal
like very extravagant then you can use
commas in a semicolon maybe an MD and
you have this elegance to it and then
the final word is dessert and if you you
can have the best maitre d the best
courses but if the dessert is too salty
it's the worst restaurant you've ever
been to so every sentence of the book
you know starting at the first word no
one will believe the amount Cal and I
obsess to the first word we debated for
months and we decided the best word is
right ri ght right and those words word
of the whole book the whole book the the
opening sentence is right this way and
that sets off the whole tone of the book
it creates the creases and the final
sentence oh my god that was weeks of
brainstorm because it had to be the
perfect sentence and what's the word
that you end an entire story you know on
and it's the word home it's beautiful
thanks Zack so of all the people that
you interviewed all the wisdom that you
collected the most impactful was the guy
who helped you write the book seems like
to you personally Cal yeah it's crazy
because I set off on this journey to
learn from Bill Gates and to learn from
Buffett and to learn from Spielberg and
while I did learn so much from them and
what they taught me
you know changed me forever the greatest
and most valuable thing that happened on
this journey was both Cal fust Minh and
Elliott busines being like family mm-hmm
so let's talk about Elliott for a minute
I mean this is really fun become your
mentor in right in this is my bed and
I'll say this on this podcast I want to
plant my flag in the ground in 20 years
he will be one of the most you know
impactful names in business
the only reason no one knows him right
now is because he's purposely by design
tried to avoid all you know public
opinion and attention attention but I
can see that I mean I love Elliott and
his wife you know Julie and I have
become close with them and I think the
world of him and I think what he's built
is so extraordinary you know it's so
extraordinary that like I can't wrap my
head around it like it doesn't make
sense
and maybe a good way to kind of launch
into this part is like I first became
aware of like these summit people many
years ago long time ago a friend a gob
teacher called up Julie and said hey I'm
supposed to go teach this class at this
house these Pele I can't do it I gotta
go to attend we just fill in for me and
Julie wasn't like really a yoga teacher
at that time but as a favor to a friend
she said sure and here's the address
good as she goes to this house it's like
I don't know 15 people malar in Malibu
this was many years ago yeah I mean it's
had to be 2002 or something a long time
ago she comes back from that experience
and she's like I don't know who these
people were and like it was kind of
weird like I'm in the house and it's
sort of like a commune and I and I
taught yoga to these people and they're
all like so engaged and like friendly
and present and so much so that it like
weirded me out like I'm like what is
happen oh what these people are doing
but there's something going on here you
know and then I think it was a couple
months later where there was like a
double-page out in Vanity Fair and
they're all like walking down the beach
together and she's like those are the
people I thought you
and that was my first introduction to
what some it is and then I started to
learn about what they were doing and you
know I now been to eat in these people
like Elliot you know at at with Elliot
at the helm this group bought a mountain
you know Utah and they're creating this
community and they host these annual
events or biannual events were they
bring incredible speakers in and Bezos
was the one of the best speeches I've
ever seen a man and they cultivate this
community around ideas and I think it's
truly remarkable and I think Elliot is
somebody whose heart is in this amazing
place and the team of these build is
incredible
it's disheartening when you read press
and it they don't get it or it gets
missed sort of you know they're
portrayed in a way that that is
different than I think it what is what
then one's real but I have nothing but
the utmost respect for Elliot and what
he's created it's mind-blowing and how
he came into your life is a crazy story
oh my well it's funny cuz we sort of
touched on that moment a little when I
was sharing when I was in that CVS
parking lot on the phone of Bill Gates a
chief of staff he said two things right
get a book deal and go build momentum so
you know I had some thoughts on how to
get that book deal or figure it out but
the word momentum like what the I'm 19
I'm like what the [ __ ] is momentum and I
remember going back to my room that
night and just like literally my head in
my hands like momentum I'm just sitting
there like rocking in my chair and I
don't know how this happened but you
know sometimes like just thoughts flurry
in your mind when you're just in a panic
so I'm just thinking like momentum like
if I'm only like 5% of therefore Bill
Gates I must be at like negative 20%
with you know Bill Clinton or Richard
Branson and I'm like wait pillow Clinton
Richard Branson didn't someone tell me
last summer that Richard Branson was on
this I cruise ship or something it's
almost like procrastinate I take on my
computer and I Google like Bill Clinton
Richard
and cruise ship and this article pops up
and it's on Fast Company and it is like
Summit Series takes the high seas with a
cruise ship packed with richard branson
gary vaynerchuck the routes as the house
banned by the pool Blake Mycoskie
leading shark tagging Tim Ferriss
canoeing like it's just I was like what
the [ __ ] is right it sounds like this
like you know entrepreneurs dream and
I'm reading this article and it's like
Elliott busines the founder and CEO of
Summit Series with many companies to his
name is 26 years old and I'm like what
26 is like my cousin's age she's like
how is that possible I thought you have
to be like this big CEO so I just start
COO like Google Elliott there's no and
I'm just ripping through it going down
this rabbit hole and you know I miss
like two meals without noticing and I'm
just clicking and clicking and a weird
thing about him is that there was a lot
of articles that mentioned him but none
that actually said what he did so it was
almost like I was this detective trying
to piece it together it's part of the
whole mystique right I learned later
it's by design and it's almost like
googling the guy from catch me if you
can you think you're onto something and
then you get thrown off and some
googling and googling and by the end I'm
like if there's one person on earth who
can you know teach me about momentum and
show me what I need to do to get to Bill
Gates it has to be this guy and I
remember this night very vividly I you
know closed my eyes and set a prayer and
then I opened my journal and I at the
top rode dream Mentors
and I underlined it and on the first
line I wrote Elliott busines in a couple
weeks later I was again studying for an
accounting final this time and I
couldn't stop thinking about what it
would be like to instead be learning
from Elliott
so again I can't focus on finals so I
just some like alright let me get out of
my head and out of my system so open my
computer and start writing this email
for Elliot but I end up spending three
hours writing what I think is like the
perfect email I used the Tim Ferriss
cold email template I email Elliot I
send it off and literally the next
morning he goes great email
what are you doing Thursday and I look
at my calendar and Thursday it's my
accounting final so I say the only thing
that I can I'm completely free and and
just to kind of put a put a punctuation
mark on this your greatest skill might
be finding all these people's emails so
like there are surprisingly a lot of
very effective systems but do you know
what's crazy actually this is wild
it was easier for me to find Bill Gates
his email address than it was to find
Elliot's
Wow so when you email Bill Gates you are
actually emailing billion you weren't
like emailing an assistant or some nosy
but with people of this caliber they
have assistant to readers we read their
stuff and filter out the junk so what's
left in his inbox is stuff for him and
so I got intercepted really quickly
anyway yeah all right so somehow you get
Elliot's you know through some kind of
cyber well for Elliot's actually I can
tell you the way I did it for him
because I remember I couldn't with all
my methods it didn't work so with him I
was like alright I'm just gonna pick you
know ten of the likely things that might
be and I just get he's literally ghost
it I put them all in the BCC field and
one of them was there I got nine bounce
backs and one didn't bounce back that's
smart so he ended up responding and you
know so I say I'm completely free and he
says great meet me at this hotel I
therefore this conference in Long Beach
and before you come like read a chapter
of this book and this is like my jury
mentor so if he says read a chapter I'm
reading the whole book right so I read
the whole book I'm sitting for my
accounting I look it is unbelievable
book it's called when I stop talking
you'll know I'm dead by Jerry Weintraub
mm-hmm unbelievable book and for anyone
who's like an entrepreneur on their
hustle like this is one of the greatest
empresario z' of the you know 20th
century and i go I think all right it's
not a big deal Elliot's gonna meet with
me for 15 minutes my accounting final
isn't until noon it's only the hotel is
only an hour away from school I can
still make it on time what ends up
happening is I show up the morning of
you know 8:00 a.m. I get there early
Eliot walks in right on time our
15-minute meeting turns into four hours
and it turns out that we're meeting at
the Westin Hotel in Long Beach during
Ted which is the main lodging of the TED
conference
so I'm sitting at this breakfast room
with you know everyone I you know Larry
Page is sitting five feet away and then
over there's Tony Hsieh then over there
is Reed Hoffman and I'm 19 and I'm like
what what it's literally like The Wizard
of Oz right from black and white to
color and my for our meeting with Eliot
turned into an entire summer traveling
the world with him to now him being one
of my best friends that's amazing what
do you think you said or impressed upon
him in that meeting that that clicked
with him I
there's no way to know for sure but I
think when it comes to having a mentor
they can only help you as much as you're
willing to help yourself so I knew that
everything Elliot would advise me to do
I'm gonna go you know 10x so you know he
says hey can you read this chapter for
me I'm gonna read the whole book he says
hey I remember when we had first met
like I didn't have any you know I was 19
I didn't have like a debit card or a
credit card or anything and he is like
you [ __ ] idiot like how do you expect
to be travelling around I thought so you
know the next morning I opened up like
you know I just did everything he
advised you know to the 10th degree and
what you know my theory is that when
someone like yourself or like Elliott
who you know has very them at a time if
you're gonna invest in a young person
you want to make sure there's some you
know in addition to doing it out of the
kindness of your heart you want to make
sure there's an ROI that the advice
you're giving is actually going
somewhere and with Elliott everything he
told me you know I ran with it and you
know it started small and it got bigger
and bigger and bigger to the point where
it's now not only a mentor relationship
he he was standing at my dad's bedside
when he took his final breath mm-hmm
he's very much like family wow that's
amazing
you know I think it's pretty rare I mean
she you have Calvin and and Elliott as
like you know on your speed dial as this
as this kid I mean you're I think your
talent really is your people skills you
know your ability to connect with other
human beings I appreciate that I know
that that's been the history of our
relationship and I don't know how much
of that is teachable versus just the way
you're baked
hmm so first of all I appreciate that
I've thought a lot about you know what
things I can pull out that I've learned
along the way
and you know I've made a ton of mistakes
so while my relationship with you know
you or Elliott or Cal is great you know
there are some relationships that I
completely [ __ ] up on you know to a
point where I might blacklisted from
some people's well it might be on
Elliot's me down black listen some
people just like this crazy guy just
won't stop emailing me kind of so with
so like Warren Buffett for example I
spent like I told I spent this
eight-month quest you know trying to
track him down and I spent literally
eight full months it wasn't part time
you have to understand every morning
waking up I'd put in my headphones at
6:00 a.m. run down the sidewalk
imagining Warren Buffett was at the end
as I'm doing my Sprint's like obsessive
and I would write handwritten letters to
him that I would take weeks editing and
I'd hand write these letters and mail it
to him and he would actually handwrite
some responses back so is this like very
awkward pen pal so thank you Alex
thank you Alex go he was much kinder but
that was essentially what it said and I
just got every week calling Buffett's
assistant week after week after week and
it almost felt like I was in this you
know boxing you know world championship
with you know this young kid who's never
picked a boxing gloves versus you know
Floyd Mayweather and I'm just getting
pounded in the gut punched in the face
you know I'm bloody I'm spitting up
blood you know my insides are bruised
and you know each rejection felt like
I'm just getting pounded and by the end
of these eight months you know I phone
to Omaha I had sent so stupidly Buffett
a shoe to try you know I did all these
crazy things where at the end of the
ain't much you sent him a shoe oh this
is a very embarrassing sorry we so
someone who was advising me who had said
he worked for Buffett was like trust me
on this
they'll think it's funny and I was like
sure
I can go in it's a whole nother it was
in this fire it was a giant misfire but
pretty much I kept pounding because I
just believed every business book says
persistence is the key to success so I
thought the more I pounded on the door
the sooner out yeah breaking down into
that but ultimately you end up
bum-rushing his shareholders meeting
right correct so I ended it tossed out
like oh okay so for that what ended up
happening was you know after this eight
months Buffett's assistant you know she
knew me she I had sent her flowers again
right yeah she knew who I was and she I
think felt bad for me and she goes look
I know Warren I know he's not gonna say
yes so why don't you know as my guest
you come to the shareholders meeting and
I was like oh my god like thank you so
much do you think I can they bring some
friends she's like of course so she
sends me six tickets and when I'm on the
phone with her I'm like hey her name is
Debbie I'm like hey Debbie
isn't it true that people at the
shareholders meeting and the audience
can ask Warren Buffett questions and she
goes Alex Alex I know what you're trying
to do but it's just not possible
there's 30,000 people there and only 30
ask questions your odds are one in a
thousand I wouldn't get your hopes up
but Debbie doesn't know I'm the king of
hopes up and you're also the guy who
figured this out with The Price is Right
fly your prices right tactics - so
what's funny is it actually was very
similar to the prices right in the sense
that it's advertised as this lottery
luck system but there's a system and the
odds aren't exactly the same so me and
my you know five childhood best friends
you know again Kevin is with me we go
there we end up finding a loophole in
Buffett's lottery system and out of the
six of us although the odds were 1 in a
thousand four got winning lottery
tickets and that's
how I asked Buffett my questions and the
question was so there was four different
questions one was about raising a fund
another one was about negotiating skills
another one was about you know value
investing another one was about how he
focuses his time but but like straight
up questions he didn't get up and say
hey it's Alex no no my thinking was look
you know I have let's say 20 questions I
wanted to ask him in an interview all
right let me take the top four and ask
them in front of 30,000 people
mm-hmm what ended up happening is you
know Buffett I think caught on to what
was happening and by the time my fourth
friend went up the spotlight turned on
Buffett saw my my fourth friend and goes
well this is a great time to end the
shareholders meeting thank you for
coming and you know who knows what if he
knew what he was doing but it was a
right very create this in my friend eyes
he started asking a question that
microphone got cut off right so Debbie's
like but you sent him this right tell me
that you said I haven't said so could
you not have sent this to him with a nut
with a note saying like I think he'll
fall into his hands eventually I don't
want to like rub it in his face but what
ended up happening after the
shareholders meeting was I ended up
interviewing Bill Gates in the interview
with gates went so well that his office
was like look how can we help this
mission and I was like well I still
really would like to sit down with
Warren Buffett and they go easy they
contact Buffett's office and I'll never
know what was said but I do know that
gate guy yeah essentially what my
assumption is they're like we know all
about Alex we're not doing this right
and gates his office sent me an email
like very terse please no more contact a
Buffett's office Thanks whoa and they're
like my buddy you're like they're right
we're fright so yeah I was like oh my
god and what I learned finally I learned
my lesson that there's a
such thing as over persistence you know
you can bang on a door so much then
they'll call the police and no business
book talks about that no one talks about
the dangers of over persistence and I
realized I had dug myself into such a
deep hole that even Bill Gates gonna
pull me out yeah you need I mean that
level of you need you need EQ you need
emotional intelligence to be able to
read those cues and understand where
those well exuberance got the best of
you without one I think yeah good lesson
to learn so in in the in the wake of all
of these people you know Lady Gaga's
Spielberg my Angelo Wozniak Jessica Alba
pitbull that's like I'm too old they
like understand that when it was a good
interview so we don't have time to talk
about all these people but is there I
guess my question is like what is the
through-line like what is the consistent
you know piece of advice or what is it
that that unites all of these people
that you talk to if you could like
condense that down into some wisdom that
the person who's listening to this or
just going to read this book is gonna
take away with them when I had started
out on the journey
I was very cognizant of I'm not looking
for this you know one silver bullet you
know we've all seen those TED Talks or
those business books you know the one
key to success and it's I sort of roll
my eyes what ended up happening was as
they went on the journey you know do
these interviews and on that outside you
know Bill Gates in Maya Angelou could
not be more different
right like Maya Angelou grew up in rural
stamps Arkansas gates you know a wealthy
suburb of Seattle to a rich lawyer and
you know I just kept doing these
interviews and about like 70% of the way
into them I started realizing that
almost like a good musical album there
was like a common melody to every
interview
and the analogy that came to me because
I was you know 21 at the time was that
it's sort of like getting into a
nightclub so I realize is life business
and success it's just like a nightclub
there's always three ways in there's the
first door the main entrance where the
line curves around the block and that's
where 99% of people wait in line hoping
to get it you know you're standing there
with your resume there's the second door
the VIP entrance where the billionaires
and the celebrities go through and
school and society have this way of
making you feel like those are the only
two ways in yeah they're born into it or
you wait your turn like everybody else
for what I've learned and what you know
very well is that there's always always
the third door and it's the door where
you jump out of line run down the alley
bang on the door hundred times crack
open the window go through the kitchen
there's always a way in and it doesn't
matter if that's how gates will this
first piece of software or how Lady Gaga
got her first record deal they all took
the third door so that's not only the
title of the book and the thesis of the
book but that's really the energy I'm
trying to inject into the next
generation
it's it's another way of saying you have
to think creatively and out-of-the-box
like there's always there's always a
solution that's not immediately
self-evident if you're willing to
experiment and explore and you know be
unconventional in your and grab life by
the collar you know roll up your sleeves
get messy get dirty there's always
always away but I would say this to you
young Alex Benari and not everybody is
cut out to go through that third door
some people are just wired to you know
they're they're better off in line
waiting to go through the front door
what I've learned is that in something
that I had to learn along the way is
that taking that third door isn't always
about you know yelling Stan your scarf
you know that that's what worked for me
you can look at Chi loo for example he's
one of the most fascinating people I'd
ever interviewed
my life he grew up in as Chinese guy
right yeah he grew up in a village
outside of Shanghai China with no
running water no electricity people were
so poor that they walked around with
deformities from malnutrition for every
you know we think our education systems
mad in America for every 300 students
there was one school teacher so those
are the circumstances he was born into
and he's you know very quiet you know he
was smart so he worked very hard and by
age 27 he was making the most money he
had ever made in his life seven dollars
a month fast forward 20 years later and
he's a president of Microsoft and his
story is and you know throughout the
book there's a lot of people who you
know
aren't these extroverts who are very
introverted who are very quiet who do
like to stay in line
but the third door isn't about you know
being wild and loud or you know being
crazy and creative it's about doing
whatever it takes to find a way and
taking your life in your hands and
making sure that you're gonna do
everything you possibly can to make
happen first you got to figure out what
that is
yeah you know that's a struggle you went
through you know I can't help but listen
to you and and try to think how that
relates to my own life experience and of
course you know I struggled for a long
time trying to figure out what I wanted
to do and you know I'm sitting here with
you today only because I had to figure
out my version of your third door which
was a door into a room that you know I
don't know that there were too many
people and you know it's like it's yeah
it's not like I'm trying to break into a
room where there's a bunch of people
already there it's like I'm trying to
find a path to something that I don't
even know exist like there's no template
for it like learning as you go but I
think I always bring it back to that
internal journey of like trying to
really figure out what it is that I'm
trying to express in the most honest way
possible so that before you start trying
to break down the third door you want to
make sure it's the the right third door
yeah absolutely so how do you think you
figured that out for yourself well
Elliot told me this great quote once he
said sometimes going down the wrong path
leads you to the right one and I think
that's very true but that's only if
you're paying attention in you're
listening for me when I started with
this book it was never to be an author
it was you know I wanted to find out
this information share with my
generation move on to what I actually
wanted to do with my life
for me as this journey has unraveled
I've realized that in many ways it's so
closely tied to what I feel my purpose
is and again I didn't it's not this
overnight realization and I'll tell you
this story that I heard once it it's
this woman she's teaching and Baltimore
for Teach for America and this really
you know tough school and she's teaching
you know young kids you know eight years
old and you know it's just they're in a
really tough neighborhood so she decides
one day she's not gonna do the math
lesson she's going to I think you know
grab some paper and some crayons and
help them write and draw their biggest
dream in life so she passed out the
paper and the kids are running and you
know coloring and everyone's having a
lot of fun and then there's this one kid
in the back who like is frozen and she's
watching him and about halfway through
he has this idea and starts calling in a
picture and at the end of the lesson you
know she collects the papers and at the
end of the day she's flipping through
them and sees that he drew a pizza
delivery man mm-hmm
and she calls the mother that night
because she was concerned and the mother
wasn't surprised the mom said the only
man in his life
not on drugs or in jail as his uncle who
delivers pizza and what that story
showed me is that young people will
always strive for the highest branch
they see possible it's our jobs as
society to illuminate those branches and
in many ways when I had started this
book you know we talked about how I
wanted it to be you know very
informational like you know queuing days
and while there's still a ton of
practical and tactical lessons and tools
in the book I've learned that you can
give someone all the best tools and
knowledge in the world and their life
can still feel stuck but if you change
what someone believes is possible
they'll never be the same mm-hmm and
that's very much what my purpose is with
this book yeah I believe that that's a
good purpose to have thanks man you know
I think what's interesting about you you
know one of the things we kind of didn't
even get to we glossed over is the fact
that like no part of your story is that
at 19 you become this venture capitalist
you get hired by a VC firm you're like
the world's youngest venture capitalist
it gets a lot of press there's articles
about you and like fortune and stuff
like that you make the Forbes like 30
under 30 my question for you is I mean
ultimately you made this choice to like
not do that anymore so that you could
finish this book I would imagine there
were a couple people who told you that's
crazy that you had this you know
burgeoning career as a successful
venture capitalists like why did you how
did you make that decision to walk away
from that so the book is actually what
led me to the VC job and when I first
joined the VC firm and there are
incredible people they knew from day one
when I started working with them that
the book was my number one priority so
it wasn't really this like shocker plot
twist as much as them saying you know
thank you for all you've done it feels
like now's a good because it got to the
point where
you know my book was always my number
one thing and something can be your
number one
taking 80% of your time but it sort of
becomes unfair to that number - mm-hmm
so I still love venture and I think it's
fascinating and my time with Alsop Lilly
partners was incredible but to me it was
a very obvious decision of my heart is
this book my heart is this mission and
venture was this great opportunity along
the way right and what's really insane
about how this is unfolding is that
you're going off and like giving
keynotes at Nike IBM Apple Harvard and
essentially from what I can tell this
keynote is all about like the third door
this book which is it hasn't even come
out yet like okay let's say the book
comes out it does huge then you go talk
to Apple it's like how are you - hit on
my history of my life as somebody who's
like you know been doing this for a
little while I'm like I haven't spoken
it Apple or IBM or hard like how are you
doing this what's going on Alex will you
be my mentor you're way too smart for
that
um it's crazy cuz when I was I think I
was maybe nine I was 20 when I got my
first like corporate speaking engagement
it was it was with Nike uh-huh and you
know I had like talked a little before
about the book of they're all free
things like a startup thing or this
entrepreneur thing it's the two year
promotional tour for the book which
turned seven year promotional tour for
the book what's been very fascinating to
me is you know I started out writing
this book really initially just with my
friends in mind
you know we're going through this life
crisis we don't know what we want to do
with our lives we don't know how to
break through I'm gonna write this for
us and I had mentioned this slightly
before which is I learned that the book
is less about a specific age than a
stage and I learned that through
corporate speaking where these big
corporations would reach out to me which
I you know it wasn't like I was pounding
the phones for corporate gigs because I
was pounding the phone trying to get to
Bill Gates my focus was on finishing
this book what I realized is that
there's tremendous value in not only
stories that inspire risk-taking but
also someone coming in to help break
down the science of it and that's what
I've been doing with a lot of these big
corporations which is going in and
really decoding the art of risk-taking
for them you know breaking down the
steps also telling the crazy stories
along the way and obviously I think it's
gonna be a lot more fun when they can
actually hold the book you know starting
uh-huh starting now but over the past
few years these keynotes have been even
surprising to me of how well they've
gone because I didn't understand because
I've never worked in a big corporation
how hungry they are for that kind of
energy and that kind of insight because
we've talked about it sometimes it gets
very you know linear there where there's
a lot of bureaucracy and innovation only
happens with risk-taking and I didn't
know this at the time but this book in
many ways is a an entire study on
risk-taking you know how Bill Gates
dropped out of school and started
Microsoft you know how Spielberg you
know snuck onto the universal lot to
become the youngest track all these
crazy stories in the end well baby
here's your story you know right right
which is your own risk-taking adventure
and journey to this right or in my mom's
words how I made her life a hell for the
past yeah but they're good now right
really might yeah all right we got to
wrap this up but I don't want to end it
without I think a good place to kind of
land the plane is to talk a little
about your relationship with your dad
who passed away this past year and you
know I know you're somebody who's very
close with your family so I'm interested
in you know how that process of letting
go and kind of being there when he was
passing how that's informed your
perspective on your career your life
ambition what's important and what's not
it was you know goes without saying the
hardest thing I've ever gone through in
my life not only the dying process but
there's something idea it's there's
something very life-altering to see the
person who gave you life like in front
of you taking his final breath and what
I've learned is what matters in the end
I it's weird to almost like couch this
into the story of what we're just
talking about because I when I was
starting out I think it was this like
subconscious belief that at the end of
life you know if you really succeed if
you do really well there's almost this
like trophy at the end and if you do
very poorly
you know you get punished and you know
my dad had pancreatic cancer for 14
months or he probably had it for longer
but from when we found out his diagnosis
to when he passed was a 14 month period
whereas pretty much 14 months of me
sitting with death every single day you
know going with my dad to the chemo ward
sitting down at the hospice people
reading on grief and grieving you know
really yeah I'm the one who told my dad
he had three months to live when you
that much time with death he learned how
to live and you find out what matters in
the end you know for the final about
Wednesday Thursday Friday Sunday for the
final five days of my dad's life he had
no access to anything that today like if
he was alive he would count us giving
him pleasure you know food he loved food
he couldn't eat
he couldn't drink he couldn't talk my
dad loved to talk loved to go that we
couldn't do that he couldn't he loved to
like watch TV he couldn't open his eyes
he had no access to money possessions
literally every material pleasure was
gone for this final five days and I
remember the day he first slipped into
his coma where I was at Elliot's
apartment it was a Wednesday morning and
I got a call from my dad's doctor saying
she had just visited him at home and it
looked like he had just a couple days
left to live and though it's very hard
to describe what that feeling is because
it's not like a cognitive moment it's
not a you're not thinking of like all
right what to do it becomes and although
you know that call was coming at some
point it's one of those things that once
you hear and like everything changes so
I called my sister who lived not too far
away I like picked her up in the car or
we went to go visit my my dad at my
parents house let me get in there and I
see my dad and my mom and my dad's
caregiver because he was on Hospice in
the living room but my dad visibly did
not look the same I had seen him you
know a day earlier two days earlier
where he was moving around and talking
and he was very still and his skin had
yellowed and
his breathing was very labored I
remember like trying to you know touch
his hand and see if he was resting and
definitely wasn't resting and I remember
sitting on the couch with my sister
looking at my dad and you know realizing
mmm
slipping into a coma and a few minutes
later my dad's caregiver said it was
like time for him take his pain
medication because with pain grant
pancreatic cancer was very painful
mm-hmm it's literally like imagine like
a football growing inside of your
abdomen so all those nerve endings are
being squeezed so I knew if he didn't
take his pain medication and he had
slipped into the coma very rapidly so
there wasn't time to get like an IV in
him or something because he was at home
on Hospice so he had to take this pain
medication so that you know the
caregivers trying to give it to him and
she's a sing David please open your
mouth and he's unresponsive and you know
she's asking over and over and over
again and I'm I'm really panicked and
then my mom stands up can she like kicks
off her shoes and grabs the pill in her
hand and like kneels down on the floor
and I remember like seeing her I'm
sitting on the couch and she's kneeling
down and she puts her hand on my dad's
hand and the second she opened her mouth
and asked him to open his mouth his
mouth opened seamlessly she took the
pill and swallowed it very easily and I
remember just sobbing in that moment not
out of sadness because I wasn't solving
my summit the coma I was scared when I
saw in the coma but in that moment I was
sobbing out of like the beauty of it and
what I learned that day is that I
remember writing that down that night
was that
like at the end of life when you don't
have you know access to money or
possessions all you have is your breath
your heartbeat and your connection to
those you love and that's you know
probably the biggest lesson my dad's
ever taught me and how have you carried
that into how you live your life now you
know if my dad didn't pass and this
sounds weird cuz I am you know working
as hard as I can on this book launch
because I care about it so much but I
would probably be doing it and being a
lot more tightly wound and probably
miserable because what I learned is that
look I want this look this is this book
is my dream you know I spent seven years
on it I wanted to you know do as best as
it possibly can and touch as many lives
as I possibly can but I also I saw the
end I know what when I'm dying it
doesn't matter if I'm the best selling
off their it doesn't intrude ly it
doesn't even matter how many lies I've
touched while that does matter to me
personally in the end what matters is if
the ones you love are like sitting
behind you beside you and it's shifted
the priorities to the point where you
know again if my dad hadn't passed you
know Mother's Day is this month and
Father's Day is next month like I
probably would have guys I can I got to
stay at the office it's a no-brainer for
me to take the entire day off forget
about having a Mother's Day breakfast
it's a Mother's a day and it's helped re
prioritize in a very major way that no
no lesson from Bill Gates ever could
have given me yeah I mean I'm just
sitting here thinking well this is the
most powerful you know lesson that
you've learned in this seven-year
exploration yeah and it's crazy he
passed away
as soon as the book was done Mike and he
was he had his wits about him enough to
know what you were doing and everything
yeah yeah
why that's a good place to end it my
friend thank you man I appreciate it
yeah it's powerful I'm super proud of
you you stuck with it the book is
amazing they did an incredible job and I
think it does have the potential to
impact a lot of people so I can't wait
to see it out in the wild I don't want
to see it in the airport next time the
airport and anything I can do to help
you man it means a lot yeah much love
Alex thank you cool so the third door
you can pick it up wherever you buy
flying books independent booksellers
Amazon all those good places are you
doing any talks that are open to the
public or book signings or yeah
absolutely it's on my book website so
it's the third door book calm thi Rd
third or book calm
yeah the tour stuffs on there are you
doing like a full tour or you know in a
multi-city kind of thing you're gonna do
that yeah yeah cool it's gonna be really
fun awesome man
all right we'll come back and we'll talk
some more thank you man this was really
really enjoyable I appreciate it cool
piece